[Music]
our commitment of marriage has kept us
going until a couple weeks ago he
blindsided me and told me that he
doesn't love me
doesn't know if he ever did
and he is tired of being the pillar of
my life
you're worth more than all of this
[Music]
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr john dolone show
so glad you're with us
james i know we're gonna talk about this
at the end
america how do you like these apples
u.s recorded music sales
volumes by format
for the first time in almost two decades
in 2021 according to data published by
recording industry art association of
america
shipments of cds rose from 31
million to
47 million
suckers cds are coming back
and ben you don't know what a cd is
there's a small disc that
has on it
it's incredible and earlier
so inside baseball um there was
something i needed james to send me
um right when i started the show and i
said hey can you burn this onto a cd for
me and i was in a room full of engineers
and young audio folks
and they looked at me like hey james you
take your shirt off and just dance for a
minute that was basically the same
question
they had no idea what i was talking
about and even he was like you mean wait
you owe me to what i have since then
bought a cd burner yeah
i know it's like buying a covered wagon
to take your parents to the marketplace
with or something like that but hey man
cds are coming back told you told y'all
you with your little subscriptions
and by the way i'm glad you have
subscriptions that's probably how you're
listening to the show if you want to be
on this show give me a shout at
1-844-693-3291
it's 1-844-693-3291
we talk about mental health
relationships school anything that's
going on in your life so glad that
you're with us let's go to heather and
saint paul what's up heather
hi hello
hello
hi
you know thank you for the lighthearted
cd talk that was i appreciate it do you
buy cds
well i mean i haven't in 15 years but
thanks for kicking me while i'm down
there sorry right hmm
once you call one of those newfangled
shows they probably have is it the mp3s
or no they stream it now
so what's up
all right can i give you a little
backstory first absolutely
all right so my husband and i have been
together for 20 years okay we have an
eight-year-old son
we have walked through infidelity job
losses addiction miscarriages and my
mental health
issues of anxiety depression okay and
our commitment of marriage has kept us
going until a couple weeks ago he
blindsided me and told me that he
doesn't love me
doesn't know if he ever did okay and he
is tired of being the pillar of my life
he's
refusing any counseling he's only
surrounding himself with people that
he's known for less than a year okay
he says that he's excited to move out
and get a motorcycle and have space to
spend
time with our son
which i'm calling all the bs yep but i
can't be the one to call him out on it
okay
so how do i help him
and how do i minimize the tornado of
damage that is coming
to
coming my way in my son's way
i'm sorry heather
yeah i was gonna say i've been married
for a long time why'd you get married to
you
well we didn't get married we've been
together for 20 years
married for 15. okay all right
man
so
there's a lot lot here you you and i
could probably spend a couple hours
together i'm guessing right
yeah
yep um there's a lot yeah
so
can i be super truthful
absolutely painfully so
yeah okay
to i'm gonna answer your question and
we're gonna work backwards together the
reason i don't like to do that is when i
answer your question i'm afraid your
body not you but your body is to shut
off listening to anything else i say
well i'm used to that so yeah
i'll try to stay with you stay with me
okay and if that means that you just nod
and say cool great good which has
probably been part of your survival
techniques the last 20 30 years um you
can just go back and listen to the
recording of this okay
okay
to answer your question
there is 100
absolutely nothing
you can do to convince your husband to
do things differently
yeah zero you don't have that power
hopefully that is both terrifying and an
immense relief
because it's not a mat him leaving him
departing him running away
is about him not you
okay he will make you the bad guy
the same way when there's economic
crisis in countries countries rally up
and point at somebody or some group or
some other country as the reason
he has to have somebody to blame for
running
and you are that person
yeah
um you were
you're a partner with him you're a
romantic partner so there's all kinds of
variables and this isn't that
but when he cheated on you
it was about him not you
when
he had addiction challenges those were
about him not you not things that you
weren't doing you get what i'm saying
a hundred percent and so
um the great
esther perel says most infidelity
happens because someone doesn't like who
they have become inside of this
relationship
not
because my partner's gained weight or
isn't pretty or whatever
i don't like who i have become in this
and so i'm going to go find
a that energy that electricity somewhere
else because i don't like me
and you just that's what addiction is
that's what infidelity is and now you're
telling me this is this midlife crisis
i'm just gonna shake the snow globe up
and i gotta go i gotta i don't like who
i am in fact i hate who i am
and i'm blaming you
and that's gonna be my ticket out the
door because i can't just stand up and
say i need a break i can't stand up and
say i hate my job i hate who i've become
i am not exercising i'm not lifting
weights i'm not taking care of my mental
health i don't have relationships all my
friends have i've cut he can't say that
stuff out loud that takes a level of
strength and bravery he doesn't have
yeah and so
he he's and i hear me say his feelings
his fear his terror inside of him that
is 100 real
yeah he feels the existential clock
ticking loudly so loud he can't sleep
um my guess is he's got demons that are
his entire lifetime old is that fair
yeah yeah he's been 100 he's been
running from himself for a long time
so
you can't change that
and i hate that for you because your
life is his life and his life is your
life and you have a sweet beautiful
eight-year-old
tell me about this tell me about this
eight-year-old he is
the most wonderful
little guy he is empathetic
and loving
and wants everybody in the room to light
up
and he dances through life and i never
want him to stop doing that yeah
so he will
this is going to be hard
it's going to be very hard for him yes
and you can't absorb this for him you
can hold his hand through it
and do you get the difference there
oh yeah
i'll give you a really extreme example i
may have even given this on the show i
was talking walking somebody through a
situation where
um
it was my uh somebody who's close to me
their
girlfriend had a son sorry so it's kind
of removed the sun did some terrible
terrible things and
the question was do we get a lawyer and
go through all this and try to reduce
sentence and get this guy off and i said
i don't want this human on the street
because i have kids
and my friend said you're exactly right
i'm 100 with you what do i tell this
grieving mother and it what i ultimately
said was
you can't keep him out of
the court you can't keep him out of this
process but you can hold his hand during
the sessions that's what a mother can do
and so in a
sideways analogy here circling back to
you
your son is going to have a dad who
leaves
and that's going to put you in that
category you know what i mean
yeah and that like just being in that oh
i'm one of those
couples families now like that we're
that we're dead left
and because i was because the wife was
too much that story we've heard it's a
cliche at this point
that's y'all now and he's gonna have to
experience what happens when a dad walks
out and dad says we're gonna spend tons
of time together buddy they're not
i know dad's gonna get into his
motorcycle and his new friends in his
new club until he falls off whatever
wagon he's climbed up on
and you know that and my guess is if he
struggled with infidelity and with
dishonesty and he is i mean with
infidelity and with
um
addiction he's probably a
world-class liar
is he good at that too
no he's a terrible liar but
he gives he gives it a world-class
effort maybe
maybe yeah
okay yeah
so you can't you can't
shield your son from the fact that his
dad's about to walk out on him and his
mother
the hardest part is for 20 years
i have been trying to protect this thing
and it's like it's all imploding right
now and i can't i have no control
yeah
no anything
that's right
and
the quicker you can exhale and say okay
what about this can i control
and what about this can i not control
the quicker you move there
the quicker your feet you know you've
ever been at the beach and you get
washed out and you can't touch and you
can't touch and suddenly you're like
whoa whoa you just panic a little bit
and then you find footing
even though the water's up to your neck
you find footing and you just go okay
that's the moment you say okay i'm gonna
start trying to control what i can
control here i'm gonna let the rest of
this nonsense go
um cool
so um i got this from my friend dave
ramsey he says the moment somebody says
i'm divorcing you i'm out
this is no longer a relationship this is
now a business transaction
yeah and i will as a part of a business
transaction protect my interests which
include my child
yeah and so
this is the moment when um that old
awful saying you may be through the past
but the past isn't through with you
this is when the conversation's about
your infidelity and your financial
infidelity and your
abusive behaviors and your addictions
all that it becomes part of
the narrative that i'm going to use to
protect my child
yeah right nothing personal you said
we're done great now now we're moving
i'm moving forward with that information
and so
do you weaponize somebody's past no but
you you do use the facts available to
you for the safety of your kids so where
do you find yourself you can't control
him his decision to leave his decision
to pull the plug on your marriage and
can we be honest for a second
yeah your marriage has been trouble for
a long long time right
yeah just band-aids over band-aids
that's right so in some regards he's
just throwing the lights on on this
thing right
yeah
and some of it i told him he had the
courage to do what i couldn't there you
go there you go
and so in that regard
fair enough
whether it's it's you're there's
probably a lot of chicken or egg here
whether your mental illness led to he
thinks to this or
the fact that you've been sharing a bed
with somebody that you were 10 000 miles
away from spiritually intellectually and
psychologically
um contributes to that
mania and that pervasive feeling that
you're not enough and that just
low-level depression that runs through
your veins right when you're in a
relationship with somebody but you can't
figure out how to bridge that gap
um yeah those things those things feed
each other right so here you are the
lights are on great
i can't stop you from leaving here's
what your life will look like when you
leave
and then you get to decide i'm not going
to put this stuff into your heart and
mind you get to decide what that is
that's what you can control
you can control whether you decide to go
see a counselor starting today
you can decide whether you say i'm going
to
be about exercising every day even if
it's just strolling for a walk
i am gonna triple down on skin-to-skin
contact with my eight-year-old three
times a day four times a day not in a
i need him to prop me up
but in a
this is gonna heal him and heal us both
right this is just a way i'm going to
settle them down you get to decide those
things i'm going to get all the little
debbie snack cakes out of the house and
i'm going to eat well even if i want to
throw this salad across the house like
i'm going to do the things that i need
to do to stay well
because the next season is going to be a
mess
yeah
that's what you can control
and those are the things you're going to
say with me
it's all i mean that's it that's all you
can do right i know
there's not a song you haven't sung
there's not a
bar class that you could have gone to
there's not some crazy acrobatic thing
in bed you could you didn't try
it's not that
it's he's choosing to leave
because he's got demons chasing him
and i'm gonna help him so you can love
him
but until he decides he's going to help
him
um
he's going to just keep running
yeah
and running and running and running
i'm i'm heartbroken for you
and at the same time at the same time
there could be a bright light on the
other end of this thing you know why
you're worth more than all of this
all of it
you're worth more than the infidelity
you're worth more than looking in the
mirror and thinking you're not
attractive enough
you're worthy of knowing where the money
is in your home
you're worthy of not wondering if he's
coming home if he's coming home and
who's these new people and a motorcycle
what you're worth more than all of that
yeah
i am
you are can i tell you one word i want
you to keep in your mind
yeah you've heard me say it before i'll
say it a million more times you gotta
practice
you're gonna have to practice loving
heather because you haven't you've been
trying to hang on for so long
yeah
will you practice that
absolutely
practice the way you think practice the
way you talk practice all of it
so hang on the line i'm gonna send you a
copy of it's it's just it'll be out very
very soon of my new book on your past
change your future here's the thing is
it's gonna walk you through how to deal
with the
last 20 years last 30 years probably and
then it's going to give you us
like here's what we do now
and the book's not preaching at you it's
just me walking alongside you
because i've been in a hole too
okay i'm going to send you a free copy
of that
you're going gonna make a phone call
today to somebody
i will okay you gotta have somebody one
two three seven you gotta have people
who walk with you in the season
i will the waters will get rough
and you'll be able to touch
yeah
and thank you so much hug that little
boy a little extra tight just for me
i will i will okay
yes hey your bravery and your strength
and your willingness just to say what do
i do
[Music]
there are millions of people in
relationships
that are on the brink
saying how do i get them to how do i get
him to how to get her too your bravery
to have this conversation today is going
to help a lot of people out there thank
you so so so much
check back in with us because i want to
hear how this one plays out we'll be
right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important that you are worth being well
and therapy is a super important way you
can show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
hey we are back let's go to
marimere scarborough what's up mary how
are we doing
i'm good how are you doctor john rocking
on to the brink of dawn what's up
well thank you so much for taking my
call of course i'm uh
i'm a new teacher at a public high
school
um
when did you start that job
about
two years now two and a half oh no
okay go ahead
just in time for
oh
that's like becoming a house framer as
the hurricane hits the
hits land
yeah it's been pretty crazy
um understatement so
i've been struggling with anxiety um
during the school day i'm
having i guess what you would call a
panic attack
body shaking
having a hard time breathing and
i just want to continue teaching because
i do enjoy it but it's affecting me so
much
in my personal life and just my physical
well-being that
my question is how can i find that
healthy balance of
you know being an engaged
teacher
focused on kids while also not facing
burnout oh man
what a great call
and
can i just give you a little bit of
light in your day
the fact that
you were just able to do something that
it takes many of us myself included
years of counseling and work to do you
are able to pull apart
what you're passionate about what you
love
what you
see yourself doing as a career and the
fact that your body is taking off on you
and most of us jumble all that together
and then we try to just do life with
duct tape and netflix and your ability
to pull those apart sets you so far down
the road like it's exciting for me to
talk to you mary it's awesome
so
um
when your body starts like doing what it
does when it starts shaking your stomach
gets to that warm feeling you know
um like in your i don't know it's that
it's a it's like somebody puts a
backpack on like a weighted vest but
it's inside it's in like you're in your
body you know what i mean that yeah that
yeah it drags like you're dragging your
guts down but they're not going anywhere
what what's happening what's making it
set off like that
well there's different
levels i guess like you know there's the
morning where
i'm just panicking that the lesson plans
go accordingly and
um that everything goes well but then
there's also more severe things of like
you know aggressive students that made a
verbal threat the previous day and i'm
nervous about seeing them in the hallway
or
just
from everything from the teaching but
also
teaching has kind of been secondary
lately because it's just more behavior
and
helping students social emotionally um
and worrying for them and their safety
yeah
all right so i'm gonna free you from
something and i'm gonna
be the bad guy here too okay
you cannot heal all of these students
you're carrying too
much and i don't even go as far to say
is you're not equipped or even trained
to
take care of all of the mental health
challenges and the physical health
challenges and the behavior health
challenges that your kids are bringing
to the classroom every day
and i also know there's not always a lot
of options for a teacher
but you're carrying stuff because you're
an incredible lovely caring human being
and
i have been there
and it was a revelation to me when i
realized oh that's not my job i can't do
that
i can be a voice i can be an ear i can
be a presence
but i can't be your therapist i can't be
your social worker i can't be your
your behavioral interventionist i can't
be your ada support network i can't be
any of those things i can point you to
the right person
but my job is to teach chemistry
my job is to teach whatever and to show
up and look in the eye and make sure you
know i love you that's what i can bring
and when you start letting go of some of
those other responsibilities right now
your body's rattling on you so think
about like you have like a
toyota corolla
and you're trying to move in the corolla
and so you have every your couch is on
top of that thing and your dog is in
there and all of your like clothes and
the car is just rattling down the
highway they can't go anymore because
you got too much weight on it
and so i want you to think about the
things you're carrying that
isn't within the bounds of what your job
is is to be carrying
one of those is fearing for your safety
you should not go to work every day
scared that someone's gonna hurt you
is that a real fear or is that one that
is just a new teacher fear and
i'm kind of i'm carrying it a little bit
heavier than i probably need to be
a little bit of both you know like
there'll be periods of time where
you know i have a particular student
that i just having a hard time
um
getting through to and you know they
kind of lash out
but then there's also just fears of you
know school shootings happening and
like not feeling the school is doing
enough for security and to keep us all
safe and yeah
so if you're not safe
don't work there
if there are violent students then
you're not being backed up you need to
get yourself out of there
okay
do what
i just feel like i'd be like
the kids are then left behind and um
and i just feel like i shouldn't abandon
the
students
your heart's incredible
but you drowning is not going to help
students
or you ringing the bell on a school
that's not protecting his teachers or
its students maybe you can go that route
but what i'm hearing you say is i'm not
gonna stop and put on my oxygen mask
first because these kids are gonna be
missing their air
and what happens when that when that
goes down is everybody loses
your kids will not benefit they won't be
more your kids can only be as well as
you are
you can't give them what you don't have
you can't give them peace in their life
if your body is so anxious that you're
having to go in the hallway to catch
your breath
and i know that sounds counterintuitive
i've been there i got hit in the face
at my with this at my first year of
teaching the first week of my first year
of teaching
and they weren't trying to hit me
they're trying to hit somebody else and
it winged me right in the right in the
head
and so cow's like oh is this how this
roll like this how this goes i've been
there somebody hit me in the face
um
and
i had a team i had a group of
professionals that really took care of
my classroom took care of me took care
of the whole situation and so i never
felt that lack of safety i'm also a big
guy so i know that's totally different
too
um
how are you taking care of you
um you know i try to
go on walks every day and
try to do some meditating in the morning
before going to work
something else here
what is it what am i missing
um this is deeper than burnout
i guess i kind of
you know i have my own personal trauma
as a kid
and i didn't really acknowledge them
until i started teaching where you meet
students that have
similar trauma and you're just kind of
being yourself yeah
will you tell me about your
what you went through
just uh
emotional
and sexual abuse
i'm so sorry
for my dad
man
and so you're the catcher in the right
now
you're standing at the edge of the cliff
that you got shoved off of
and you're making sure that none of
these little kids get shoved off too
ma'am
that's so much to carry to work every
day mary has so much to carry to bed
every day
oh man i'm so sorry
thank you for being brave and sharing
that with me
so here's your path forward okay
yeah
path forward number one
is i want you to get the book by the
nagatsky sisters called burnout it's
beautiful and it's brilliant it's
written for women okay
i read it i love it i give it to men all
the time but it's specifically for
um
working women okay
one of the cornerstones of the book is
once your body kicks off a process
a fight or flight response there are
some things you have to do in order to
be okay
wellness is a verb not a place
it's not a thing you get to it's a thing
that you do
and
i talk to leaders all over the country i
talk to teachers all over the country i
talk to medical professionals
lawyers whoever
and i tell them over and over and over
again your clients can't be okay if
you're not okay
the people you're operating on can't be
okay if you're not okay
and what i'll tell you is the best gift
you could give your students
is to get them in touch with
professionals and for you to say i'm
worth being well
and it sounds counterintuitive because
it's going to feel like you're letting
go of the rope
and you've been holding onto that rope
for a long long time right
yeah real real tight too
can you do that
yeah
do you need to take a break from
teaching for a season and get well and
then come back
probably i do look for other jobs on a
daily basis
i mean maybe i try to quit every day but
maybe yeah
so there'll be two there'll be two
things about that if you get another job
number one the smoke will clear a little
bit
but you'll go with you
yeah
have you ever seen a trauma counselor
have you ever addressed what happened to
you as a kid
i uh
tried to go to counseling um twice then
i
didn't further pursue it okay
because you didn't it was hard you
didn't want to go down the rabbit hole
or because it was just you didn't get a
good therapist
uh not a great therapist okay
do me a favor and go back find somebody
new
you're so worth that oh my gosh you're
so worth that and there will be a
classroom full of young people that your
kids benefit from you being there every
day don't get me wrong like they are
they won the lottery with you as a
teacher
um
but there's going to be a group of
students you stand in front of in a year
or two and you're going to be completely
well are you going to be on the road to
well you're going to be living a well
life let me put it that way
that doesn't mean you don't have
flashbacks it doesn't mean you don't
have hard hard days that doesn't mean
you you have days you can't get out of
bed doesn't mean any of that but it
means on most days you do
and
their entire family tree is going to be
different because they got to interact
with miss mary
they got to
go to class with miss mary and they may
not remember i don't even what do you
teach what's your subject
math and science okay yeah i just picked
chemistry out of the air way to go
deloney like they may not remember
chlorophyll and they may not remember
you know the pythagorean theorem
but they're going to remember that
teacher cared about me
that they are worth being loved
and their parents didn't show them that
in fact they had some dad that really
hurt them bad
but miss mary cared about me
and what's what's a mole
10 times x to the 62 or something like
that i don't remember yeah is that it
uh you're almost there yeah
told you guys i'm a genius
james and kelly think i'm dumb way to go
he made me feel good mary you hear what
i'm saying
so here's the path forward
if you screw up a lesson plan what
happens
are you asking me yes
um
i'll answer for you quickly nothing
nothing
if you blow a lesson plan
in 2022
your students go
and then you pivot and you do something
else
so every day you come to school as
though this lesson plan is for the super
bowl it's not
so plan
set it up
and if it goes sideways cool we're on to
the next
uh teachers are have been have been
forced to live and die by this
lesson plan for the last 25 years 30
years when it became the bible we're
done with that now
breathe
the kid mouths off to you and especially
kids meld off and they're scared and
terrified too if a kid mouths off to you
now and
says something like i'm gonna hurt you
then you go to the administration first
via email and then in person so it's in
writing and you say this student has
threatened me they are not welcome back
in my class
until there's some sort of remedy there
and then it's their job to make sure
that kid is safe and that you are safe
and the rest of your class is safe
the data on school shootings is
virtually never
yeah virtually never
it's possible of course
virtually never
way more likely to get in a car wreck on
the way to this uh to school than that
way way way a thousand times more did i
just give you something else to worry
about
way to go to loney idiot
i want you to take care of your mental
health i want you to take care of your
physical health i want you to have
friends i want you to laugh
i want you to go to happy hour with a
group of complainy teachers again
i want you to
i don't know go to the teacher lounge
and just roll your eye i want you to get
your life back
is that cool
yeah
you're worth getting your life yeah and
you don't have to quit by the way i
threw that out there
usually as a test question when i say
maybe you need to leave and people are
like no
then i know where their heart is yours
was yeah yeah i may be
so go with what's right for you right
now and it might be this i need to take
a season off i've been there it's all
right it's cool
or maybe you need a summer because this
has been two years of holy smokes and
this isn't the whole teaching field that
promise promise promise mary
oh you just started in the middle of wha
but you can't give your kids what you
don't have
so i'm giving you full 1 000
permission as a former high school
teacher
and as a guy who pretends to be a mental
health guy on the radio on a podcast
you've got permission to take care of
you for a season
okay
okay
you believe me
yes
you're so great all right
hang on the line i'm gonna do a couple
of things for you i'm gonna get you
hooked up with
i'm gonna give you one too i'm gonna
send you a copy of the new book also it
sounds like this is like a book
promotional show it's just not we just
had two calls right in a row um
it's gonna give you a road map out of
this thing okay
it's also going to walk alongside you as
you deal with the front end of this deal
what happened and then what comes next
okay
but it'll give you some language to take
to a counselor it's going to give you a
road map out
and
it's going to you can hold on to it
you're not going to be anchorless okay
is that cool
yep yes
you have a friend in your life you trust
i have a sister no
she doesn't count so do you have a
friend
no no does your sister know about your
abuse
we were related to a little bit of some
stuff yeah
grief demands a witness
so here's your homework assignment
not to go through the rigamaroos of the
trauma not to go down rabbit hole
because you need to be with a
professional to do that someone who's
given you some tips on some some new
tools on how to be safe and to feel your
body as you're going through this stuff
but
you need to get somebody you can trust
and be honest with and it might be a
counselor in this season or it might be
that your body is
really rattling because it's not safe
it's an environment where things you
can't control and it is completely alone
it's lonely
and i want you to be intentional about
making some relationships in this new
season so that you've got some people to
hold your arms up when you go through
the hard stuff
okay you are worth
friendships you're worth relationships
you're worth telling a student
let me i need to stop you right there
i'm so heartbroken for you do i have
your permission to give you a hug and
you give a hug and say i'll walk you
down to the counselor's office
you promised you wouldn't tell miss mary
i i know but i
i'm taking that back and that was my
fault
what you're experiencing right now is
really serious and i'm going to take you
down to the counseling office because
you need to have somebody who's trained
in this that's going to walk alongside
you
and you can pray for him on the way back
and you can breathe it out and then you
are not carrying their breaks anymore
too heavy you're carrying your own right
now
you are worth being well miss mary we'll
be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so
thankful for people like my friends at
churchill mortgage churchill is a ramsey
trusted provider who we've been sending
people to for over 20 years to help with
home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me
that's triple eight loan two hundred
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back uh unamazed let's
go to lauren in springfield illinois
lauren what are you doing
yo i am cleaning someone else's house
[Laughter]
hey
uh do you have the permission to be in
there
yes actually
this time this call would have been such
a better call if you're like no i broke
in
i thought we were on something okay i i
never have done this i don't think i
don't remember on the show
um kelly gave me
the kelly jenna gave me
your email
can i read it
yeah go for it
here's what
here's what you wrote
i always get like a sentence or two
that's like
like hey this call may be about this
especially if it's like
um i've got some diagnos i got ocd i've
got narcissism disorder whatever so that
i can make sure i'm calling the right
experts to make sure i know what i'm
talking about
this one she just gave me the email here
it reads
i feel by the way this call should be we
should be sponsored today by
the everyone's favorite drink in a bag
capri sun
[Music]
i feel like i'm a capri sun
and my husband daughter and even my dog
all have straws
yes
i'm feeling overworked out touched
and exhausted
i want to meet the needs of my family
without feeling drained in the process
can you help me work through this
dude email of the day
really
well i mean it's not like a contest with
points but you did go no did no
tell me what's going on that's such a
it's an incredible picture you painted
for me
i'm very descriptive i think i try to be
very descriptive i love it everything
i love it um
that was sent at like 2 30 in the
morning
i was laying in bed
i was like i feel like i'm at my wit's
end so that's when it happened okay and
several things have happened since then
and things have gone a little better no
no no
no i know people like you
and
you're walking it back because that's
who you are
yes that's true don't walk it back tell
me what's going on
okay
well i
quit my job after working for almost
seven years as a dental hygienist i quit
and i have decided to start my own
business
and cleaning and getting permission in
people's houses and so you stopped
cleaning people's mouths and you started
cleaning their toilets
what more do you want like it's a it's a
meticulous cleaner
i bet you're amazing at this okay so you
couldn't you quit your business you
started your own job okay yeah yeah and
so i
have an incredible husband i have such a
sweet two and a half year old daughter
and i have a six-year-old boston terrier
and i am everyone's favorite in this
house i am the glue my husband calls me
the glue that holds everybody together
everybody loves to be touched and loved
on and
loves it when the house is clean and
then at the end of the day i just feel
so
yeah i exhausted
very trained and i feel bad that i feel
bad that way because i love them all
very much but there's times where i'm
like laying in bed at 2 30 a.m feeling
like a capri sun yeah your body isn't a
wonderland your body's a jungle gym it
might be a wonderland that's not for me
to say
but it's a jungle gym so
listen
who told you that your job was to take
care of everybody else that's a that's
an old story you've been playing for a
long time
yeah yeah and you know what i'm the
oldest of four i'm a product of divorce
[Music]
and i'm a peacekeeper hey there you go
so atd is a response to yes to chaos
it's our body's way of making dealing
with chaotic
it can be maternal environments i mean
prenatal environments it can be
um childhood adventures probably both
and in your case
and
god almighty and you also got to play
mom number two right
yeah yeah i did and so my mom
she has high expectations of herself
all the time and i think i translate
that into high expectations of me and if
i don't
keep things a certain way then i feel
like i'm letting her down too i think is
what i internalize it as gotcha so it's
just
and then i end up shutting down and just
trying to keep everybody happy is my
default and then i don't realize it
until i'm totally frazzled and then my
husband's probably kind of shocked too
so
yeah that's kind of where i'm at how
long have you all been married
we have been married going on three
years we've been together for about six
and it's been a whirlwind i'll tell you
what we got together and about a year
and a half later we were engaged also
renovating a house also living in it and
then planning a wedding and then we're
like hey let's have a kid
so we did that
[Laughter]
so i feel like
there are days i feel like i really
didn't take the time to get to know him
as well as he got to know me
and he doesn't know you
maybe not he doesn't
um that's fair to say
i'm gonna rattle off a series of
questions that i don't want you to
answer
okay
when's the last time
you said
you've got dinner this week and here's
what i want to eat
when's the last time you said
this is the kind of sex we are having
and i'm taking the lead
when's the last time you said i'm off
bedtime duty for five days in a row
because i'm exhausted
or i need you to be at home and because
i'm going to the gym and i know it's six
o'clock but this is going to be best for
me
those questions sound nuts to you
yeah
okay
and so
your husband has an incredible picture
of a hilarious
super fun
up for anything
wife
he's got a great picture of a
rock star human being someone who will
work themselves until their body's like
and we're out
and we're done
yeah it will wake up at 2am with to
remind you of the guilt which is the the
gasoline that keeps the engine running
that engine
ultimately melts together and never runs
again
yeah and that's what i'm afraid of that
ultimately we're we're going to raise
our daughter and then look at each other
and say who is this person in my house
get out
[Laughter]
or you're going to inadvertently present
a picture to your daughter of this is
what getting through life looks like
and if she happens to have your
um
bubbly joyful personality she'll be able
to fake it too
but she might not she might just be more
of a quiet introvert she might be
someone who likes to
get her head screwed on straight and
then go out into the world and the
world's going to destroy her for it
yeah and so
the greatest gift and this is going to
sound counterintuitive the greatest gift
you could give your family
is to start answering these questions
what do you
want
and what do you need
so that
you can show up and help other people
with what they
need the greatest gift a husband and
wife can give each other is to be really
articulate and clear here's what i need
right now and then the other partner
says here's what i need right now and we
work together to help as best we can
meet each other's needs so that they can
then help meet our needs and then we end
up in this beautiful psych circle like a
wedding band and it never stops and the
needs change over time and the beliefs
change over time and the things that i
think are fun or not fun change over
time things i think are sexy and not
sexy change over time but we keep
showing up and saying all right what do
you need in this season what do you need
in this season and here's what i need in
this season and you leave out the other
part of that equation
yeah
yeah that's true and i don't want to
it's not to blame your you're you never
blame it two and a half year old they're
just two and a half they don't know
um and i'm not going to blame your
husband he just sounds like he's a great
human being this is just the deal he
signed up for this will be weird
it will be different and
the men i've talked to and this is me to
included
think the end of the world has come
when their
wife starts speaking up
and it's much better to speak up
because you
desire it not because i have to or i'm
going to end up in ashes hear what i'm
saying you can own this or it just
happens all right usually after kid
number two or three
and somebody's on the brink of an affair
or whatever like we are
somebody loses a job and then it all
comes out
it sounds like you're not quite there
yet you're on the front end of this deal
that you can say hey
i've kept what i need quiet for a long
time and you're such an amazing partner
here
here's what i'm gonna start practicing
speaking up for needs these are called
boundaries by the way i'm gonna start
speaking up for these things along the
way
and
will you work with me on this
invite him into this my guess is he's
gonna be all about it
yeah yeah he's really good about
you know he's like just say what you
need
that's what i struggle with that's right
okay so give me a couple of hints
nope not a couple of hints give me a
couple of things
hold on
you were not allowed to tell your mom
what you needed
because what you needed didn't matter
nobody cares right
and your three knuckleheaded brothers do
you have all brothers
i have a brother and a sister and
another brother a younger brother that
was in the next marriage yeah okay oh
that's even more fun right
that's a whole lot that's a whole other
call exactly
so
um they could give the five box of farts
what your needs were they don't care
right and
so saying your needs out loud got you in
trouble
it hurt you your body had learned over
time do not say these things out loud
because we're not allowed to
and so you're gonna have to fight your
own body for a season and don't not
physically but you're gonna have to walk
alongside yourself as you learn how to
say things out loud because your body's
gonna say if you say that out loud he
might leave
if you say a need out loud he might say
i'm not doing that
probably he won't but that's gonna that
weight is gonna be so
a lot you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
yeah and so i already feel it yeah i
know you did so
practice with me
give me a couple of needs
i need
to go to bed and the dishes are done
okay and the living room looks like
nobody lives there so every morning i
wake up it's like a fresh start
okay
and
so let's let's drill into that one need
what's one step below that so what does
that mean
so
that means you know he works a later
shift than i do no no no no
annie and i are in her bed and he comes
home and he does have time to be able to
do that and so when i wake up
um and if things aren't done i'm like oh
well you had a golden opportunity
brother does he know
that
i've said in the past that i don't think
it got through or it wasn't said the way
it was most meaningful probably
so clear is kind
here's the best way to have this
conversation
i'm practicing
saying my needs out loud and this is
hard for me because i've never done it
and mom used to get really like wouldn't
hear it so i love you and we're gonna
practice this together is that cool and
he'll say that's cool of course
and say
from the hours of six to nine o'clock
i have
to feed a kid
feed an adult
feed two adults
we've got dishes we've got house
gotta get this kid bathed which is at
two and a half feel by the way that that
changes in a few years it's so great
when they just start bathing themselves
it's like you get your whole life back
it's coming okay hang in there but i
gotta bathe a kid
i also need
whether you think so or not i need the
house like for me to sleep i need the
house to be clean
and that's also the time we do it
so
there's only so many minutes
i can
spend time here i can spend time here or
i can spend time here
and
if he's like most men i know he'll be
like
sweet consider the dishes done i'll even
right we can figure some of that out and
by the way
some days
my body has been in service to this two
and a half year old
and so it is not gonna be up for in
service to a
29 year old too
i need my body back
okay yeah i feel that i've breastfed for
way too long man i'll tell you what no
longer anymore obviously but
i will feel like obviously
yeah you're just getting it back and
that's a whole other phone call too but
all that to say is this
practice speaking your needs out and
practice being very very clear
um this is also a great time for him to
have permission to say his needs out
loud too
and so
this is when you can say okay cool we're
gonna start putting
cleaning on the calendar
or our nighttime routine you're gonna
take a lap around the house make sure
the dishes are up make sure the counters
are wiped off and make sure the living
room is cleaned up it's gonna take
literally seven minutes to do those
three things seven minutes
and your wife gets to have a full night
of sleep
right right and he's gonna say
i need it's been two and a half years i
need more intimate time with you great
we're going to put that on the calendar
monday wednesday friday you can think
about it all day i'll even send you
weird text if you like whatever we're
going to think about like
but we're going to put on the calendar
that way we're both on the same page
here then your needs are going to allow
me to meet your needs and then my needs
are going to allow you to meet so and
now we're working together hear what i'm
saying
yeah and then we both give a little then
one of us won't be trying to give
everything
you know well if you both give a lot in
service to each other true then you're
you see what i'm saying
yeah right now you're having to survive
because everyone's draining you
let's flip that thing around and while
you're filling other people up he has
now plugged his straw back well that's
uh that this is gonna get awful so i'm
just gonna leave it there he is helping
you and you're helping him how about
that
yeah is that cool yeah all right yeah so
here's the here's the step forward
you initiate it
because it's gonna be hard for you this
is the homework assignment you initiate
the call
the conversation you say
saturday morning i'm getting a
babysitter you and me are going to
breakfast and we're going to talk about
needs
so his homework assignment over the next
48 hours uh is to write down like some
needs that he has
some things that that bring him life to
bring him joy to bring him connection
and bring him peace and you will bring
yours and yours are not less than
because
he's gonna say things like i need to
hold the baby and you're gonna say like
i need the dishes done
all of the needs count all of them
and then we're gonna sit down and say
okay let's get an actual calendar and
see how we can make this work let's see
how we can make this work let's do this
together and then we're going to
practice it because there's going to be
a night he forgets to do the dishes and
you're going to wake up and think oh my
husband hates me he does and he forgot
you're going to remind him and he's
going to go ah i know i know and he's
going to get it done and then there's
gonna be a night that's a wednesday
night and he's got a starbucks you're
gonna be like dude i'm so tired he's
gonna be like but we head on the
calendar and be like i can't i know okay
we're we're going to practice meeting
each other's needs so that
each other can meet each other's needs
so that each other can meet each other's
needs and off into the future together
you
my sister lauren
are amazing and i don't say that lightly
he is lucky to have you your baby girl's
lucky to have your communities lucky to
have you and now i want you to be lucky
you have you
you're worth
saying here's what i need
we'll be right back
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something list chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be
if your actions aren't working for you
anymore that's okay
now's your chance to get up and choose
differently and that doesn't have to be
complicated in fact in my new book own
your past change your future we'll walk
through a common sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be johndaloni.com to start creating
the life you want that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
we are back
and jenna brings me the lyrics of the
day a little bit on the nose here as we
wrap up today's show
there's a heavier show thank you all for
being with us
it's
the john mayer classic the award-winning
grammy-winning classic three chords
not your body is a jungle gym but your
body is a wonderland and it goes like
this
we got the afternoon
you got this room for two
one thing i've left to do discovering me
discovering you
your body
is a wonderland
[Music]
i'll see you soon take care
[Music]
coming up on the next episode it's only
when she's at her mom's honestly all
these pictures all these videos all this
stuff any other screen that she has
access to at all period
is a choice for an adult to ruin her
life
how do i navigate interacting with my
manipulative and unfaithful
ex-girlfriend who just told me she's
pregnant with my child didn't see that
one coming
so give me a second here i'm going to
speak super directly probably in a way
that nobody's spoken with to you is that
okay yeah because i'm your friend and i
love you and you're we're
we're neighbors now cool
okay
he might die
[Music]